ثلاثه اسابيع من الصراع في السودان هدوء
حذر في الخرطوم بعد انفجارات واشتباكات
صباح اليوم
الامم المتحده تدعو الحكومات لعدم اعاده
اللاجئين السودانيين لبلادهم بسبب الصراع
لافروف يجدد استعداد بلاده للحوار مع
الغرب ونائبه يحذر من مواجهه مسلحه بين
موسكو و واشنطن
القائد فاجنر يتهموا وزير الدفاع الروسي
بتعمد قطع الدعم عن قوته ويهدد بالانسحاب
من باخمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في تغطتنا
لتطورات الاوضاع في السودان وايضا
واوكرانيا نبدا بشان السوداني 21 يوما من
الصراع في السودان لا جديد يذكر اشتباكات
عنيفه بين الجيش والدعم السريع تجددت في
الخرطوم وشمال كردفان مراسل العربيه
افادها بسماع ذوي انفجارات ضخمه في
الخرطوم وبتحليق للطائرات في سماء العاصمه
صباح اليوم قبل ذلك اكد الدعم السريع في
بيان قبوله تمديد الهدنه الاثنتين وسبعين
ساعه ببساطه سعوديه امريكيه والالتزام
بوقف اطلاق النار كما اعلن الدعم السريع
ترحيبه بالمبادرات المحليه والاقليميه
والدوليه لوقف اطلاق النار بهدف فتح ممرات
انسانيه وتسهيل حركه المواطنين
هذا وجدد السفير دفع الله الحاج مبعوث
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقاليه التاكيد على
ان الهدنه الحاليه في السودان انسانيه
مؤكدا عدم وجود اتفاق او مفاوضات مع قوات
الدعم السريع
تحدثنا عن اهميه الهدنه ذكرت لهم ان السيد
الرئيس قد وافق على هدنه لاسباب انسانيه
اكثر من مره
واخر مره عندما
تقدمت المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بمبادره
وافق عليها السيد الرئيس
حتى انه اعطى موافقه لفتره اطول مما كانت
عليه فترات الهدنه السابقه
واوضح حسب دفع الله في مؤتمر صحفي
بالعاصمه اديس ابابا ان الجيش سيطره على
مواقع لقوات ادام السريع وانه كان من
السهل عليه حسن المعركه ضدها لولا الحرص
على المدنيه الوضع على الارض
مستقر الى حد كبير جدا
وسيطره القوات المسلحه على كثير من
الاماكن التي كان يحتلها او تحتلها قوات
حركه التمرد في السودان
ومع استمرار خلق الهدنه في السودان اعلن
الجيش في بين له عن احباط هجوم لقوات
الدعم السريع على مدينه الاوبيض بشمال
كردفان حيث توجد ثاني اكبر حاميه عسكريه
في البلاد وفرض سيطره كامله على المدينه
واوضح البيان ان قوه من الجيش اشتركت مع
الدعم السريع وكبدتهم خسائر كبيره في
الارواح مع تدمير ثلاث مركبات واضاف الجيش
السوداني ان الدعم السريع شنه هجوما على
معسكر تدريب في جبل كردفان اسفر عن مقتل
15 عسكريا بينهم اثنان من الضباط كما لحقت
مجموعات من الهجان التابعه للجيش عناصر
الدعم السريع في عدد من شوارع وازقه
المدينه وفق البيان
نشير الى اننا نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم على قناه
العربيه هذه صور خاصه تظهر هدوءا نسبيا في
العاصمه اعقب اشتباكات وسماء انفجارات
متبادله في الخرطوم حضر عدد من المتطوعين
والناشطين في جنوب دارفور اثناء تنفيذ
حمله صحيه بمستشفى نيال التعليمي حذروا من
عمليه تسليح الشباب داخل الاحياء باقليم
دارفور بحجه حمايتها معتبرين ان الخطوه
يمكنها ان تؤدي الى انزلاق البلاد في شبح
الحرب الاهليه في ظل انعدام الامن بدار 4
قالت مديره المخابرات الوطنيه الامريكيه
افريل هاينز امام لجنه القوات المسلحه في
مجلس الشيوخ قالت ان الصراع بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع سيطول على
الارجح لان كلا منهما يعتقد بانه قادر على
تحقيق الانتصار عسكريا حسب تصريحتها
بحسب تحليلنا من المرجح ان يستمر القتال
في السودان بين القوات المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع حيث يعتقد الطرفان انهما
قادران على الانتصار عسكريا ولديهما
القليل من الحوافز للجلوس الى طاوله
المفاوضات كلا الجانبين يبحثان عن مصادر
خارجيه للدعم والتي اذا نجحها في تحقيق
ذلك فمن المرجح ان يؤدي هذا الامر الى
تفاقم الصراعي وخلق امكانيه اكبر لتحديات
غير مباشره
وانضم الينا من الخرطوم الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه اهلا بك يا عمار بدايه لو تعطينا اخر
التطورات
الان في الخرطوم وباقي الولايات هل الهدوء
الان هو سيد الموقف ام ان هناك اشتباكات
اخرى حسب ما نتابع الان هناك يعني هدوء في
هذه الصوره لكن كيف هو المشهد لديك
نعم ربما الهدوء هو سيد الموقف الان في
العاصمه الخرطوم
والمناطق التي دخلت ضمن دائره الاشتباك في
منطقه شرق الخرطوم ومنطقه بحري ومنطقه ام
درمان ووسط العاصمه الخرطوم فيما يخص محيط
المطار والمحيط ايضا كذلك المحاذي لقياده
الجيش قبل ساعاتنا الان كانت هنالك طلعات
جويه للطيران الحربي نفذ من خلالها عدد من
او استهدف من خلالها عدد من الاهداف
العسكريه في مدينه بحري حيث ما زلنا نشاهد
ونتابع تصاعد اعمده الدخان من منطقه حله
حمد حيث تتواجد بكثافه هنالك قوات ومدرعات
للدعم السريع في تلك المنطقه ولكن في
اللحظات
التي قبل قليل والان ربما الهدوء هو سيد
الموقف خفضت وقلت هذه الاشتباكات ولم
نستمع الى دليل انفجارات الذي كان عاليا
في الصباح
ولا حتى التحليق للطيران الحربي ولا طائره
الاستطلاع لكن قبل قليل يعني مراسل
العربيه اكد ان ام درمان تشهد الان تحليقا
للطائرات لا ادري اذا كان بامكانكم تاكيد
هذه المعلومات من حيث انتم
نعم منذ الصباح عدد من المناطق التي شجره
الاشتباكات خاصه فيما كان للطيران الحربي
فيها من طلعات مكثفه هي منطقه بحري منطقه
حله حمد ومنطقه شرق الخرطوم ومنطقه
كافوريا ايضا في بحري وعدد من المناطق
المحازيه
للمطار والقصر الرئاسي كانت هنالك عدد من
الطلعات الجويه استمعنا الى تلك القذائف
الجويه وايضا الى المضادات الارضيه التي
ردت على الطيران من دون ان تصيب الطائرات
وفي عدد من المناطق الطرفيه خاصه في منطقه
الشمال بحري كانت هنالك اشتباكات ولكنها
خفيفه لم ترتقي الى درجه الاشتباكات
الثقيله التي كانت بالامس واول الامس
طيب فيما بتعلق بالسيطره يعني نحن نشهد
منذ بدايه هذه الازمه اشتباكات متواصله
حول هذه المناطق والمؤسسات المركزيه هل
هناك تاكيدات حول من يسيطر على ماذا
نعم يعني باعتبار ان المناطق الاستراتيجيه
تتركز وتتمركز بشكل كبير في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم مثل مطار الخرطوم الدولي وقياده
الجيش والقصر الرئاسي وعدد من المقر
الصحيه والوزارات هذه المنطقه دخلت ضمن
حيز الاشتباكات العنيفه منذ اليوم الاول
وبيانات كثيره للدعم السريع اكدت سيطرتها
على تلك المناطق حتى الجيش اشار في عدد من
البيانات الى سيطره قوات الدعم السريع على
المقر الاستراتيجيه في منطقه وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم اما في منطقه مدينه بحري فتنتشر
قوات الدعم السريع في الاتجاه الجنوبي في
هذه اذا كانت كذلك
بانه يسيطر على معظم المناطق في الخرطوم
باستثناء بعضها وايضا بعض المناطق في
الابيض وبالتالي كيف يمكن فهم بيان هذا
الجيش
نعم ربما هنا المقصود بالسيطره العملياتيه
للمعركه ولكن ما زال القصر الجمهوري تبسط
فيه قوات الدعم السريع قواتها ما زالت او
ما زال المطار ايضا منطقه اشتباك وتتمركز
فيه قوات الدعم السريع وكذلك محيط القياده
العامه للجيش وشاهدنا هذا من خلال عدد من
البيانات التي دعمتها قوات الدعم السريع
بعدد من الفيديوهات وايضا الجيش تحدث عن
محاوله لسيطره قوات الدعم السريعه على عدد
من المناطق هنا ربما عمليه تضارب ولكن
الواقع على الارض ان عديد من المناطق
الاستراتيجيه دخلت ضمن حيز الاشتباكات ما
يعني خروجه على الخدمه سيطره الجيش بحسب
بيانات الجيش الكثيره ربما تعني سيطره
عملياتيه وهو اسمى هذه العمليه بعمليه
الحسب العسكري او الضربه القاضيه هذا يشير
الى ان ربما كماشه يحاول من خلالها الجيش
ان يسيطر على منطقه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
نعم انعكس بشكل كارثي خاصه لان الحرب لا
وجه لها غير الدمار والخراب كثير جدا من
المؤسسات الصحيه والاستراتيجيه والوزارات
في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم بحسب مصادر تحدثت
الينا وبحسب الصور وفيديوهات وردت من تلك
المناطق وحتى الاسواق الكبيره في عدد من
المدن تعرضت لعمليات التخريب والدمار جرار
الاشتباكات هذا يؤثر بشكل واضح وكبير على
حياه الناس من خلال عدد من النقاط منها
النقاط الصحيه تاثرت كثير من المستشفيات
وخرجت من الخدمه وهذا بتصريح من وزاره
الصحه وعدد من النقابات التي تعمل في
المجال الطبي او المنظمات وايضا ينعكس
بشكل واضح على مستوى المخزون الاستراتيجي
لعدد من الاغذيه وينعكس ايضا كذلك على
مستوى الخدمات فيما يخص الكهرباء والمياه
وهذا واضحا باعتبارا بالامس وما زالت حتى
الساعات تنقطع عدد من المدن من خدمه
الكهرباء تنقطع فيها بشكل واضح وكبير وحتى
المياه منذ اليوم الاول في عدد كبير من
احياء العاصمه الخرطوم ما زالت تعاني من
العطش وهنالك ربما مناشدات كثيره جدا
لطرفي النزاع من اجل البحث عن حلول ومخارج
حتى تعود المياه وتعود خدمه الكهرباء لهذه
المناطق حتى شبكات الاتصالات تاثرت بشكل
واضح في الساعات الماضيه وفي الايام
الماضيه
تتدنى مره وترتفع وتعود مره اخرى ايضا
كذلك هنالك كثير من المناشدات فيما يخص
عدد من المفقودين وهذا يدل على انفراط
الامن في عدد من المناطق التي دخلت ضمن
حيز الاشتباك او حتى لم تستطيع ان تصل
اليها قوات الشرطه ايضا عدد من المناطق
المجاوره لولايه الخرطوم في المناطق
الطرفيه تتحدث عن عمليات نهب وسلب للعدد
من المناطق وخروج عدد كبير جدا من
السيارات التي تتبع للمواطنين والاسواق
التي فيها عدد كبير من السيارات تم نهبها
وسلبها وهذا يؤشر الى خسائر ماديه
واقتصاديه كبيره جدا شكرا جزيلا هذه
المعلومات عمار ابو شيبه الصحفي كنت معنا
مباشره من الخرطوم
اذا في سياق ما كان يتحدث عنها عمار قالت
المديره التنفيذيه لليونيسيف كاترين راسل
ان الوضع في السودان يتجه نحو كارثه
لاطفال يقعون بشكل متزايد في مرمى النيران
مؤكده ان اليونيسيف تلقت تقارير عن مقتله
190 طفلا واصابه 1700 اخرينا منذ اندلاع
النزاع واضافت راسل بانه يجب ان يتوقف
العنف من اجل الاطفال السودان وذلك يشمل
وقف جميع الهجمات على المراكز الصحيه
والمدارس والبنى التحتيه للمياه والصرف
الصحي كما دعت للسماح باستيراد الامدادات
الانسانيه والتجاريه الاساسيه بما في ذلك
الاغذيه والوقود دون قيود او عوائق او
انقطاع بغض النظر عن من يسيطر على هذه
المناطق واكدت تفسر ان يونس يفتدعو ايضا
الى حل سياسي طويل الامد للازمه
اعلنت قوى الحريه والتغيير بالسودان انه
ليس هناك اي طرف قادر على الحسم العسكري
وقالت قوى الحريه والتغيير في بيان ان
الحل لابد ان يكون سياسيا وان الحل الامثل
للازمه تمثل بدمج قوات الدعم السريع في
الجيش واشارت قوى الحريه والتغيير في
بيانها الى ان المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه لها الحظوظ الاكبر في النجاح
جراء المعارك بين الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع
في جنوب دارفور احترقت عده اسواق كانت في
مرمى النيران سوق التوابل جنوب دارفور من
اكبر الاسواق في غرب افريقيا واقدمها تحول
الى رماد بسبب الاشتباكات نتابع
يعتبر سوق التوابل بمدينه نيالا غربيه
السودان احد اكبر الاسواق في غرب افريقيا
واعرقها هنا في اقليم دارفور القذائف التي
سقطت عليه جراء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في احداثي الخامس عشر من
ابريل حولت السوق الى رماد الخسائر كبيره
بحسب حديثه لجنه الحصر احنا الان في سوق
الشطه يعني الخسائر بتاعتنا تفوق
التريليون دي حجم البضائع اضافه لذلك
المباني
والممتلكات الخاصه
والمستندات وكل التفاصيل انتهت الان تحت
الركام يعني
يعني لا نقول الا ما يرضي الله انا لله
وانا اليه راجعون على
مكان وتلبيته احتياجات زبائن رغم من
المعاناه والتعب ولابد لنا من انه نقدح
ونعمل لاعاده تاهيل السوق
ولكي نكسب ونعيش وناهل نفسنا ونرمم ما
تدمر من جراء الحرب في مجتمع يكابد للخروج
من ازمات عديده تاتي هذه الحرب هنا في
اقليم دارفور لتضيف عبئا اخر على حياته
طلبت مفوضيه الامم المتحده اللاجئين الدول
المستقبله اللاجئين السودانيين بعدم
اعادتهم الى بلادهم بسبب الصراع كما افادت
بيانات المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين بان اخر الاحصاءات الوارده
من وزاره الخارجيه المصريه تظهر تدفق اكثر
من 56 الف شخص الى البلاد فرارا من صراع
السودان حتى الرابع مما يجاري وفق مكتب
مفوضيه فان من بين هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين
دخلوا البلاد من معبري ارجين وقسط الملا
يقل عن 52 الف سوداني ونحو 4000 من جنسيات
اخرى
وتنضم الينا من الخرطوم الدكتوره هويدا
محمد الحسن عضو منظمه اطباء السودان من
اجل حقوق الانسان اهلا بك دكتوره يعني بعد
ان دخل هذا الصراع يومه الحادي والعشرين
كيف يمكن وصف واقع القطاع الطبي في
السودان الان
دكتوره هويدا
اذا يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بالدكتوره
هويدا نشير الى هذه الصور ونذكر بانها صور
خاصه بقناه العربيه وتظهر هدوءا حذرا بعد
ان شهدت العاصمه السودانيه صباح اليوم
اشتباكات واصوات انفجارات عنيفه وتحليقا
للطائرات الان وزير الماليه السودانيه
يقول نبدو الجهودا مع اطراف الصرع لتوفير
المواد التموينيه والوقود هذا جانب مهم
واحد تداعيات هذه الاشتباكات التي تدخل
اليوم في يومها الحادي والعشرين على كل
حال اصبحت جاهزه معنا الدكتور هويدا محمد
الحسن عضو منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل
حقوق الانسان ونحن نتحدث معك دكتوره نتابع
هذه الصور المباشره والتي اعقبت اشتباكات
مسلحه كل الهدن يتم الاتفاق عليها لكن لا
تطبق كيف يبدو المشهد في القطاع الصحي بعد
ثلاثه اسابيع من اشتباكات المستمره
مرحبا واهلا بقناه العربيه وشكرا لتغطيها
المستمره واهلا بكم حقيقه بسمع عن هدى
ولكن هذه الهدى
لا تبدو في الواقع حقيقيه
نستقبل اعداد كبيره من المصابين بمستشفيات
ويزداد الوضع سوءا لقله الكادر الطبي وعدم
تمكنه من الوصول الينا لمساعدتنا واصبحنا
نتناقص والعدد اصبح قليل
وهذا الوضع يؤثرنا والقلق من عدم امكاننا
للاستمرار في الاستمرار لا اعتقد اننا
سنستطيع ان نستمر لانه العدد يوميا يتناقص
وذلك لانه الاسقاط ارهق واصيبوا بالاعياء
وبعضهم مرضى صاروا مرضى اعداد الطواقم
الطبيه تتناقص في مقابل ارتفاع في اعداد
الاصابات مثلا ام ان هناك تراجعا في اعداد
من يصلون للمستشفيات
زعلت الاعداد تصل الينا يعني احيانا يعني
ليست كالايام الاولى ولكن كل ما زلنا
نستقبل مصابين
ولكن في نفس الوقت الاعداد اللي كانت
موجوده بالمستشفيات ارهقت للغايه والبعض
يعني
يوميا للاعلى يسالون ويتصلون يعني هؤلاء
شباب هذا هو الاسبوع الثالث موجودين
بالمستشفيات لم يروا اهلهم ولم يقادروا
لماذا لم يتم التنسيق بين وزاره الصحه
وقوات الجيش والدعم السريع كما يقوم
الهلال الاحمر السوداني هو يعني
يقيم اتصالات بين الجانبين ولذلك لكي
يستطيع العمل بحريه هل هناك مشكله
من قبل وزاره الصحه لتامين هكذا نوع من
الاتصالات لتامين ممرات امنه لهذه الطواقم
الطبيه
وعن تجمر قواديرها للعمل بهذه المستشفيات
ولكن
تصل الينا مبادرات من الجمعيات الطبيه
مبادره من الجمعيات الطبيه الاخرى لتشغيل
المستشفيات
وهؤلاء الذين يعملون بهذه المستشفيات هي
الكوادر التي تسكن بالقرب من المستشفى
القوادر الاخرى لا تستطيع الوصول لعدم
وجود
الطرق الامنه
وهذه المبادرات تاتي عن طريق اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان يعني
نقابه السودان كونه غرف مختلفه غرف طوارئ
والان تزعل لتشغيل المراكز الصحيه
التي يعني
بعيدا عن عن مناطق النزاع في بعض التقارير
دكتوره تشير الى انه بعض الكوادر الطبيه
وفئات المقتدرين يعني بداوا يغادروا
السودان باتجاه دول الجوار بحثا عن الامن
والامان هل يمكنكم تاكيد او نفي هذه
المعلومات
لا والله احنا جهه مهنيه بحته نعمل داخل
هذه المستشفيات ولكن لا ندري ما يدور من
حولنا كل الذي نزعا اليه
وبالمساعده لجام مقاومه الاحياء يعني
اسمح لي عن طريق قناتكم ان اشكر لجان حي
احياء
المقاومه الذين يسكنون بالقرب من مستشفى
البان جديد والذين يسكنون بالقرب من
المستشفيات الاخرى مستشفى التركي
والمستشفيات التي تعمل كل جانب المقاومه
عند دور كبير جدا في استمرار الخدمه
وهذه المبادرات جاءت لتعويض النقص وتراجع
الخدمات المقدمه من قبل وزاره الصحه لكن
السؤال انه هل وصلتكم اي مساعدات خارجيه
من قبل منظمات امميه او دوليه غير حكوميه
من الصليب الاحمر ومن الامس الفرنسيه وقال
برضو ايضا من وزاره الصحه شكرا جزيلا لك
كنت معنا من الخرطوم الدكتور هويدا محمد
الحسن عضو منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل
الحقوق الانسان
رحله طويله ومرعبه الى بر الامان اثقلت
كاهل هؤلاء الطلاب الافارقه وزادت
معاناتهم اخر ليله هانئه في المكان الذي
احتضنت طموحاتهم انزلت الرعب في نفوسهم
وتركت مئات النيجيريين في العراء لمده
سبعه ايام مؤلمه
حقائب مكدسه لملم هؤلاء فيها ما طالت
ايديهم اولا فلم تعد الذكريات تهم انما
الخلاص اهم
دول غنيه مثل الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
ارسلت طائرات لاجلاء رعاياها بينما كافح
العديد من الافارقه لايجاد مخرج من
العاصمه التي مزقتها الحرب
تكدس الالاف في الحافلات والشاحنات في
الرحله الممتده لثمائه كيلو متر برا من
الخرطوم الى بورسودان في ولايه البحر
الاحمر للصعود على متن السفينه بينما توجه
اخرون صوب الشمال لمسافه تبلغ الف كيلو
متر الى حدود مصر ليجدوا انفسهم عالقين في
صفوف انتظار تستمر اياما للسماح لهم
بالعبور
لكن مع تزايد الاعداد وشح الوقود قفزت
اسعار التنقل الى مئات الدولارات لتكون
بعيدا عن متناول الكثيرين ومن بينهم
الطلبه
يا من هنا وكان المكان غير الصحي ابدا لقد
كان موقفا صعبا للغايه
الحكومه النيجيريه حاولت استئجار 250
حافله لاجلاء حوالي
5500 من مواطنيها لكنها لم تستطع توفير
الا اربعين حافله
رحله على الجمر عاشها هؤلاء بالشقاء
والعناء لا يبرد وهاجها سوى حضن الوطن ولو
لم يكن حاله افضل
[موسيقى]
الان الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا
اكد وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان الهجوم على
الكرملين كان عملا عدائيا وروسيا سترد
بخطوات ملموسه واعتبر لن تحاول مهاجمه من
دون اخطار سادتها في الغرب حسب وصفه وكشف
وزير الخارجيه الروسي ايضا ناموسكو مستعده
للتحدث مع الغرب وهذا سيحدث عاجلا ام اجلا
من جانبه حذر نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
راب كوف من ان العلاقات الروسيه الامريكيه
تقترب من حافه المواجهه المسلحه مشيرا الى
ان موسكو تحاول الحفاظ على العلاقات مع
واشنطن لمنع سقوطها في هويه النزاع المسلح
واضافه بان روسيا مستعده لاستخدام كل
الوسائل الممكنه لضمان عدم السماح لاي جهه
بالتعدي على امن روسيا وسلامه رئيسها
وقيادتها السياسيه
في موازاه ذلك قالت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه في بينان لها انها دمرت احدى
طائراتها بدون طيار بعد ان بدات في
الطيران خارج نطاق السيطره على منطقه كييف
وخلال رحله جويه مخططه في كييف فقدت
السيطره على طائره بدون طيار ما دفع
القوات الجويه لاسقاطها البيان اضاف بان
الطائره بدون طيار ربما عانت من عطل فني
وتاتي هذه التطورات بعد اعلان موسكو اسقاط
مسيرتين فوق الكرملين وهو الهجوم الذي
اتهمت موسكو واشنطن باعطاء الاوامر لكييف
من اجل تنفيذه
[موسيقى]
نجمه الصمود الاوكراني كما وصفت دعمت عمود
المساعدات الغربيه العسكري وصنعت الفارقه
في الحربه لاسيما ان استخدامها جاء من
الطرفين لتحديد مواقع العدو وتوجيه نيران
المدفعيه نحوها
على اعتابك يا كانت المسيرات الاوكرانيه
اول من اقفل الباب بوجه القوات الروسيه
لتسحب ذيولها خلال ساعات وتتفرق شرقا
وجنوبا فيما الخاصره اي شبه جزيره القرم
التي زرعت الشوكه الروسيه فيها منذ تسع
سنوات تتعرض كل حين لهجمات بالمسيرات
هدفها الاولي قطع امداد المعدات والغذاء
عن موسكو واستهداف اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في سيفا ستوبول
جيش الدرون الاوكراني الذي قلل من اضرار
التفوق الروسي حجما وقدره شمل بدايه
مسيرات تجاريه رخيصه الثمن صينيه الصنع دي
جي اي مافيكا حضرت صادراتها بكين لاحقا
على اعتبار انها للاستخدام المدني فقط لكن
مسيرات بيرقدار التركيه شكلت العين
الاساسيه على اوكار الخصومه تحمل كاميرات
استطلاعيه ويمكن تسليحها بقنابل موجهه
بالليزر واستخدمت بالهجوم الذي اغرق سفينه
موسكفا الروسيه في ابريل 2022 لكن هذه
المسيرات يعيبها حجمها الكبير وبطء حركتها
وسهوله اسقاطها مقارنه بكمكاز الانتحاريه
فالعصافير القاتله او الذخيره المتسكعه
تتميز بقدرتها على التحليق في منطقه الهدف
المحدد مسبقا وتضرب عند التعرف الى العدو
تطلق من مسافات بعيده ويصعب اكتشافها لصغر
حجمها اهميه هذا السلاح ادركته موسكو
سريعا فاندفعت الى ايران لشراء مسيرات
انتحاريه عمياء بدقه ضعيفه استخدمتها لاول
مره في خركيف ثم كياف واوداسا وميكولياف
غير ان هذه المسيرات لم ترقى لتوقعات
الروس واخفقت كثيرا وفق واشنطن
على وقع تصاعد معارك في باقمه شرق
اوكرانيا اطلق مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر بروجين
تصريحات ناريه متهمة فيها وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجيو ورئيس الاركان العامه ذليله
جراسنوف بانهم وراء النقص الكبير في
امدادات السلاح المجموعه والذي يصل الى
70% حسب وصفي
ونشرت الدائره الصحفيه المجموعه مقطع
فيديو يظهر فيه مستاء من الوضع بشكل كبير
ويتحدث وخلفه مجموعه من جثث مقاتله
رئيس مجموعه فاقنر حذر من ان قوته ستغادر
مدينه في العاشر من مايو الجاري بسبب عدم
تامين وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الذخيره لقوته
وقال ان استمرار القتال في مدينه من دون
ذخيره امر لا جدوى منه بالاضافه الى تكبد
خسائر بين مقاتلي فاجنر خلال المواجهات في
باخموت
بحلول التاسع من مايو قلنا على وشك
الاستيلاء على ضخمه لكن بعد ان راوا هذا
التقدم اوقف البيروقراطيون شبه العسكريين
توريد الذخيره لمنعنا من القيام بذلك
يعتقدون انهم سوف يدخلون التاريخ ابلغت
وزير الدفاع ورئيسها هيئه الاركان والقائد
الاعلى رسميا بان رفاقي لن يتكبدوا خسائر
غير مبرر في باخموت بدون ذخيره لذا في
العشر من مايو سننسحب من
اكدت مصادر لوكاله الروسيه بان الطيران
الروسي ضربه على نقطه تمركز مدربين اجانب
للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه
الاوكرانيه حيث تجمع افراد واسلحه او تجمع
لافراد واسلحه واليات عسكريه اوكرانيه
واضاف المصدر للوكاله بان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه دمرت ايضا مجموعتين استطلاعيتين
تابعتين للقوات الاوكرانيه وافشل التنفيذ
تبادل القوات الاوكرانيه في اربع وحدات
عسكريه باتجاه محور كوبانياسك
انضم الينا من اكياف مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بك يا حذيفه قبل الحديث عن
تطورات الاوضاع الميدانيه هل زال الغموض
حول هويه هذه الطائره المسيره التي حلقت
فوق والاسباب التي دعت الى تدميرها
نعم صحيح في الحقيقه هذه الطائره هي طائره
اوكرانيه اعلن سلاح الجو الاوكراني ذلك هي
طائره من طراز بايركتار كانت في مهمه ولكن
فقد
فقدت القوات الجويه السيطره عليها ولذلك
تم اتخاذ القرار باسقاط هذه الطائره طبعا
قال سلاح الجو الاوكراني ان طائره
يعني بدون سيطره قد تؤدي الى عواقب وخيمه
لذلك تم اتخاذ هذا القرار طبعا ايضا اليوم
هنالك فيديو متداول في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لاحد المواطنين الذين خرج الى
الشرفه بسلاح وبدا في اطلاق النار على هذه
الطائره وهنالك احتفاء من المواطنين على
الاقل بهذا السلوك ويقولون انه يعني حتى
المواطنين يدافعون عن اكيب وعن سماء كيف
عموما هذه الطائره هي طائره اوكرانيه
بانها طائره روسيه وانها تهاجم العاصمه
بالنظر الى يعني استهداف الك يوم امس
بمسيرتين اتهمت موسكو كييف بالمسؤوليه
عنها
نعم صحيح طبعا تعلم انك تماما اي علاقه
لها بهذا الاستهداف للكرملين وقالت انه
هذا الاستهداف مثل هذا لا يحقق اي مكاسب
استراتيجيه بالنسبه لك هي تحشد مواردها
وتقوم بالضربات تنفيذ الضربات داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه مثل هذا الهجوم قد
يعطي
موسكو سببا لاتهام كيف بالارهاب لذلك هي
لا تتبع هذا الاسلوب كذلك ان يعني هذه
الطائره هي طائره تجاريه وطائره صغيره ولا
يمكنها ان تحقق انفجار كبير لذلك لا يوجد
سبب لتقوم بمثل هذا الفعل كذلك طبعا تحدث
المراقبين بالامس حتى وان كانت الطائره
التي اسقطت في سماكه حتى وان كانت روسيه
ايضا لا يرون سببا لذلك او انها ستستطيع
ان تحقق اي نتائج هذه الطائره يمكن
اسقاطها وتم اسقاطها بالفعل خلاف ان
الرئيس لم يكن في البلاد ولم يكن في
المكتب الرئاسي وطبعا الحديث دار عن
استهداف
القصر الرئاسي جيد الان فيما يتعلق
بالاوضاع الميدانيه واستهداف تمركز
لمدربين في المعلومات لديكم ونتائج هذا
الهجوم
نعم طبعا حتى الان رسميا وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه لم تعلن اي يعني انباء حول هذا
الامر لم تعطي اي بيانات حول عدد
المقاتلين او المهام التي كانوا يقومون
بها او يعني ان تعلن عن ان هنالك استهداف
رسميا ولكن طبعا يشاء هذا الامر الان في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ويدور الحديث عنه
وتقول ان الاستهداف من الشمال هذا ايضا ما
لم يعني الامر لم يكن في الحسبان خاصه وان
الدفاعات الجويه تعمل في الشمال وهنالك
اغلاق للحدود بشكل كامل وهذا الامر خطير
ويجب ان تنتبه وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
على الاقل الصعيد الشعبي هنالك قلم من هذا
الامر بعد ان طبعا السلطات ان الحدود
الشماليه مغلقه بالكامل والاجواء كذلك
مغلقه من هذا الاتجاه بشكل عام الاستهداف
الوضع الميداني
اشرك عبد الجواد درويش مراسل ينضم الينا
من موسكو اهلا بك عبد الجواد بدايه هل جرت
العاده ان يصرح وزير الخارجيه الروسي بامر
ثم ياتي نائبه ليصرح بعكسه تماما اتحدث
هنا عن الحديث عن استعداد
للتفاوض مع الغرب وقال بانه امر ممكن
عاجلا ام اجلا ونائبه بالحديث عن ان
المواجهه يعني اصبحت وشيكه بين موسكو
والغرب
مرحبا ابراهيم لك وللزميل حذيفه نعم صحيح
ما تقول هي تصاريح مختلفه لكن لابد من لفت
الانتباه الى ان نائب وزير الخارجيه
الخارجيه الروسي
تحدث بان قنوات الاتصال ما زالت مستمره
بين موسكو وواشنطن وهي تعمل عبر الاتصال
ويعني تهتم بشان السياسي بما يخص روسيا
والولايات المتحده بالرغم من وصول روسيا
والولايات المتحده الى الخط الاحمر حسب
قوله كما وصف هي حافه الهاويه وصل لها
الجانبان الان لكن طبعا ملف الحوار مازال
متاحا موسكو تتحدث دوما عن جاهزيتها
للدخول في حوار يمكنه حل الازمه
الاوكرانيه لكن مع الاحتفاظ بحقوق روسيا
بما يخص الملفات الامنيه وغيرها بما جرى
الحديث عنه خلال العامين الماضيين ابراهيم
نعم يعني هو سيرجيو في لقاء صحفي صباح
اليوم تحدث عن ملفات عده لكنه تطرق الى ان
موسكو لن تكون الايدي في حال تم التهديد
لامن البلاد او رئيس البلاد وستسعى بكل
الوسائل وهنا يقصد كافه انواع السلاح وهو
يعني وهي تصاريح تعودنا عليها خلال الفتره
الاخيره اما على عبر يعني على لسان مجلس
الامن الروسي او الكرملين او الخارجيه او
وزاره الدفاع بان موسكو ستذهب الى ابعد
الحدود حفاظا على امن بلادها واليوم يدور
الحديث على حفاظ على امن شخصيه الرئيس
خاصه مع وصول المسريات المسيرتين الى
الساحه الحمراء واسقاطهما فوق مبنى
الكرملين في التصريحات ايضا لافت بما صرح
به
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر كيف تعاملت الاوساط
العسكريه والسياسيه مع هذه التصريحات التي
وصلت اتهام يعني حد الاتهام مباشر لوزاره
الدفاع بعدم تزويدها باسلحه وايضا تهديده
بالانسحاب من ضخمه
نعم ابراهيم لكن في البدايه اسمح لي
بالاشاره بان مقطع الفيديو قام بتسجيله
مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر عشيه الامس تحدث من
خلاله الفيديو الاول يتحدث عنه تحدث من
خلاله واتهم طبعا راس وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ورئيس الاركان الروسي الدراسي
بعدم تزويد قواته بالمعدات وان النقص وصل
الى حدود السبعين بالمئه ولم يعد بمقدوره
المحافظ على العمليات القتاليه خرج بمقطع
الفيديو هذا على خلفيه عدد من جنوده
ملقيين على الارض يظهر من المشهد مقتل
هؤلاء الجنود لكن عاد اليوم صباحا وسجل
مقطع فيديو تحدث من خلاله على ان بقائه في
باك موت سيستمر حتى العاشر من الشهر
الجاري الكرملين ابراهيم راح يتحدث عن
علمه بنيه بريجوجن تركا بخمت والعوده الى
الخطوط الخلفيه يعني لافساحه المجال
لجنوده العلاج والخروج من الاصابات باقل
خسائر التي تعرضوا لها في تلك المرحله لكن
بعض الاراء السياسيه ابراهيم في البلاد
راحت تتحدث عن انه قد يكون اتفاق بين
الحكومه الروسيه ووزاره الدفاع وقوات
فاجنر يعني عندما يدور الحديث كان تعليلهم
عن يعني عدم تزويد هذه القوات باكثر من
70% بما تحتاجه من ذخيره لكن على ارض
الواقع هم يعني هي قرابه 50 كيلومتر فقط
يتحدث عنها بقي من باخموت طبعا تحت سيطره
لكن
دعني اذهب الى حذيفه عادل من ثياب حذيفه
البعض يقول بانه تصريحات ربما تكون مجرد
خدعه لاستهداف او استدراج القوات
الاوكرانيه
لكي تقوم بالهجوم معاكس الذي لطالما تحدثت
عنه
ربما قوات فاغنر وقوات الجيش هم على قلب
رجل واحد وان الحرب خدعه وبالتالي لا مجال
لان ينسحب من هذه المدينه المهمه
استراتيجيه
نعم الحديث يدور حول ذلك هذا صحيح هنالك
البعض يذهب الى ان هذه من خدع الحرب ولكن
ابراهيم هنا لا بد ان نتحدث عن طبيعه
الهجوم المضاده الذي تقوم به القوات
الاوكرانيه القوات الاوكرانيه لا تعمل
وحدها تعمل مع الشركائها الغربيين ومع
استخبارات عده دول لديها انتشار واسع
للاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه في جبهه
القتال تقوم بعمليات الاستطلاع بشكل مستمر
ويومي وخلال اليوم اكثر من مره تجمع
المعلومات هذا الهجوم المضاد هي تحضر له
منذ فتره طويله تقوم بحشد الموارد هي تعلم
ميقاته وتعلم متى ستقوم بهذا الهجوم وفي
اي وجهه طبعا هم لا يعلنونه وهذا ايضا من
يعني امور الحرب ان لا تعلن عن الوجهه
تحديدا وتعلم ان الهجوم الماضيه الهجوم
المضاد السابق تم الترويج له في اتجاه
خرسون وكان بالفعل في حيث لم ينتظر الجنود
الروس هذا الهجوم المضاد ولذلك نجح بشكل
كبير لذلك الخبراء العسكريون يقولون ان
هذه الخدع لن تنطلع على القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه هنالك دراسه واضحه وهنالك
توقيت محدد وهنالك حشد جاري للاليات
للمعدات وللموارد العسكريه لهذا الهجوم
المضاد وهم يعلمون تحركات القوات الروسيه
كذلك الاستخبارات
الغربيه تساعد الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
ووزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه حتى بصور من
الاقمار الاصطناعيه حول تحركات هنالك رد
يومي حتى نحن كصحفيين بشكل يومي نعلم اين
تحركت القوات الروسيه وكيف تحركت هذه
المعلومات يتم نشرها
للصحافه اين تحركت هي في موقع دفاعي ام في
موقع هجومي الان واضح الايام الماضيه
فعليا قامت القوات الروسيه في مخموت
بتجهيز دفاعات وعدم التقدم وذلك طبعا ايضا
يعني
لعبد الجواد ولمشاكل اللوجستيه عبد الجواد
توقيت الانسحاب الذي قال يعني بانه سينسحب
في العاشر مايو هل يرتبط بشكل او باخر
بموعد الاحتفال بالنصر واجل ذلك ليصبح
غاداته كي لا يحدث مشكله قبل هذه
الاحتفالات المزمعه في موسكو
صحيح ما تقوله ابراهيم يعني تم اختيار
العاشر من مايو حسب القراءه التحليليه
السياسيه في البلاد باعتبار ان عيد النصر
هو احد ابرز الاعياد في روسيا وتقوم موسكو
من خلاله بعرض عسكري كبير وضخم في العديد
من المدن قد يتم الكشف عن سلاح جديد قد
نرى معدات حديثه من الطراز الثقيل تمر في
الساحه الحمراء ان كانت طبعا دبابات او
غير ذلك بينما طبعا سماء مدينه موسكو
سيكون فيها ايضا عرض عسكري من الطائرات
والمقاتلات وغير ذلك من المروحيه لذلك
طبعا اختيار العاشر من مايو كما يرى
الخبراء هو يعني هو نصف دقيقه تاثير
الهجوم مسيرات على هذه الاحتفالات هل سيتم
اختصارها
ابراهيم حازر هل سيتم اتصال الاحتفالات
بيوم النصر بسبب الهجوم على الكرملين
بعجال اذا سمحت عبد الجواد
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد اي تغيير على
سيناريو وخطه موسكو بما يخص عيد النصر
والاحتفال المقرر منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر
اما المنطقه الجنوبيه في روسيا فستقتصر
فيها الاحتفالات على مدينه رستوف وستحتضن
طبعا ساحه النصر هناك هذا الحفل الكبير
لكن سيناريو موسكو قائم حتى هذه اللحظه
ونشهد يوميا مركز مدينه موسكو اغلاق لبعض
الشوارع لوصول المعدات الثقيله واجراء
التدريبات والتحضيرات لهذا العيد تفضل عبد
الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه كنت معنا
موسكو والشكر موصول ايضا لمراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل منكيف
[موسيقى]
اعلندا مسلسل الامن القومي الامريكي انه
سيزور المملكه العربيه السعوديه في مطلع
الاسبوعي لاجراء محادثات مع عقادتها
ومناقشه مجالات جديده للتعاون بين نيودلهي
والخليج وكذلك الولايات المتحده وبقيه دول
المنطقه
الصعيد والتخلص من الارهاب هو من اولويات
الاداره الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط اشار
ايضا الى ان الولايات المتحده ستتخذ
الاجراءات الضروريه لمنع ايران من امتلاك
السلاح النووي وانها ستسمح لاسرائيل
باتخاذ اللازم في حاله اقدمت ايران على
امتلاك هذا السلاح في سياقه متصل قال انه
سيتم الاعلان عن زياره رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو الى واشنطن في
الوقت المناسب اما فيما يتعلق بالشان
اليمني فاعلن انه تم اتخاذ عدد من
الاجراءات لخفض التصعيد هناك
انفعك دس ويكاند ابين
زور السعوديه في مطلع الاسبوع لاجراء
محادثات مع قادتها اذ تسعى الولايات
المتحده الى التطوير شركتها مع الرياض
كذلك سيزور ممثلون للهند والامارات
السعوديه لمناقشه مجالات جديده للتعاون
بين النودلهي والخليج وكذلك الولايات
المتحده وبقيه المنطقه وسوف نعلن عن زياره
نتنياهو الى واشنطن في الوقت المناسب
دعوني اذكر بما سبق ان قاله الرئيس بايدن
بنفسه وهو ان التزامنا نحو الشرق الاوسط
افريقيا ثابت لا يهتز لان هذه المنطقه
مهمه جدا من اجل مستقبلنا ومصالحها تتشابك
مع مصالح الولايات المتحده
وشركائنا الاخرين
طلب وزير الخارجيه الايطاليه انطونيو
تجانب اعتذار بشان ما تعدها روما تصريحات
مهينه طالت بعضها او طال بعضها ازمه
المهاجرين الذين يصلون بالقوارب كما الغى
تجاني زياره كانت مقرره الى باريس وذلك
بعد اتهام وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه رئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني بانها
عاجزه عن حل مشاكل الهجره في بلادها
معتبرا تلك التصريحات بانها مهينه وغير
مقبوله
الهوه بين فرنسا وايطاليا تتعمق اكثر
فاكثر باريس تنتقد وروما تستنكر ملف
الهجره يوتر العلاقات بين البلدين
الفرنسي جيرال دارمانعه
في بلادها
قال ان حكومه اليمين المتطرف التي اختارها
اصدقاء مارينلوبين عاجزه عن ايجاد حلول
لمشاكل الهجره بعد من انتخبت على هذا
الاساس تصريحات اثارت حفيظه الحكومه
الايطاليه على خلفيه ذلك وزير الخارجيه
الايطالي انطونيو تجاني الغازا كانت مقرره
الى باريس لن اذهب الى باريس للمشاركه في
الاجتماع الذي كان مقررا اهانات وزير
الداخليه جيرال دارمانان بحق الحكومه
وايطاليا غير مقبوله وز الخارجيه الفرنسيه
حاولت ان تخفف من حده التوتر اذ اكدت ان
فرنسا تريد العمل مع ايطاليا لمواجهه تحدي
الزياده السريعه في تدفق المهاجرين بغض
النظر عن تصريحات وزير الداخليه
التعاون بين البلدين يرتكز في هذا الشان
على المهاجرين من وسط البحر الابيض
المتوسط لكن هذا التعاون ورجوع العلاقات
الى حالها الطبيعي امران قد يحتاجان الى
بعض الوقت حتى تعود المياه الى مجاريها
بلال البجدين العربيه
قالت مديره المخابرات الوطنيه الامريكيه
افريلا هانز ان الصين تواصل تحدي الولايات
المتحده عسكريه وسياسيه واقتصاديا وعلى
المستوى المخابرات لتاخذ مكانها كقوه على
يبدا التقرير بجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه حيث
انها تتحدى بشكل متزايد الولايه المتحده
اقتصاديا وسياسيا وعسكريا عاد عن تاثيرها
على العالم من المنظور الاستخباراتي بحسب
نتائج تحليلنا فان الحزب الشيوعي الصيني
تحت عهد
سيواصل الجهد خلال العام المقبل لتحقيق
رؤيه الرئيس الصيني لجعل الصين القوه
البارزه شرقي اسيا وقوه عظمى على المسرح
العالمي الامر الاكثر قلقا ربما يكون وجهه
نظر الحزب الشيوعي واقتناعه الشديد بانه
لا يمكنه تحقيق رؤيه الرئيس شي جين بينك
الا على حساب قوه وتاثير الولايات المتحده
الصين تستخدم ادوات الضغط وتستعرض قوتها
لوضع ضغوط اقتصاديه وسياسيه لاجبار
الحكومات على الخضوع لتفضيلات اهدافها
البريه والبحريه والجويه والاصرار على
سيادتها على تايوان
في المقابل قلد الصيني ان هناك حاجه الى
اليقظه شديده لمواجهه توسع النيتو شرقا في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ جاء هذا بعد
ورود تقارير تفيد بان حلف شمال التصي يخطط
لانشاء مكتب في اليابان لتسهيل المشاورات
مع الحلفاء وشركاء الامنيين في المنطقه
اسيا هي مقر السلام والاستقرار وارض واعده
للتعاون والتنميه ولا ينبغي ان تصبح ساحه
معركه للمنافسه الجيوسيه توسع الناتو
المستمر شرقا في منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ وتدخله في الشؤون الاقليميه
سيقضيان حتما على السلام الاقليمي
وسيشجعان الكتلى على مواجهه بعضها البعض
ما يعني ان على دول المنطقه ان تكون في
حاله تاهب قصوى
طمنا رئيس الفلبين الصين مبددا هواجسها
بشان القواعد الامريكيه على اراضيها
ومؤكدا انها غير مخصصه لشن اي عمل هجومي
ضد اي بلد وخلال اللقاء في مركز دراسات
الاستراتيجيه والدوليه في واشنطن اوضح
ماركوس ان تقديم الفلبين اربع قواعد
عسكريه اضافيه لامريكا لا يعني انها ستصبح
مواقع لمهاجمه احد موضحا ان الولايات
المتحده لم تطلب من الاساس اي مساعده في
حال نشوب حرب بين بكين و واشنطن على
تايوان
بعد ختام الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس
الزياره استمرت لي يومين الى دمشق رحب
بيان مشترك لسوريا وايران بالتطورات
السياسيه الاخيره الايجابيه التي تشهدها
المنطقه خاصه فيما يتعلق بتواصل سوريا
البناء مع الدول العربيه وكذلك الاتفاق
الايراني السعودي حيث اكد البيان ان
استئناف العلاقات بين الرياض وطهران
بواساطه صينيه في مارس الماضي يشكل خطوه
مهمه نحو مزيد من التطورات الايجابيه التي
تخدم استقرار الشرق الاوسط وشدد البيان
المشترك على ضروره التضامن والتماسك بين
دول المنطقه لمواجهه التحديات وتوفير
الامن والهدوء عبر التعاون الاقليمي كما
اعرب الجانبان عن استعدادهما للتطوير
العلاقات التجاريه والاقتصاديه مركزين على
السبل تطوير التعاون القائم بينهما فيما
يتعلق باعاده اعمار سوريا
استكملت السلطات البريطانيه استعداداتها
لحفل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث وبهذه
المناسبه عاد الحديث عن تكاليف التتويج
وسط الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها
البلاد اذ تعتبر تكلفه العائله الملكه على
دافع الضرائب موضوعا جدليا في بريطانيا
ويزداد هذا الجدل مع اقتراب المراسم
والاحتفالات الملكيه التي تقع على كاهل
الموازنه العامه
[موسيقى]
في يونيو من عام
1953 توجت الملكه اليزابيث الراحله في حفل
كلف نحو 50 مليون جنيه استرليني واليوم
وبعد 70 عاما تقدر تكلفه تتويج ابنها
ب 100 مليون جنيه بحسب لجنه التنظيم
الفاتوره بما فيها التكاليف الامنيه
والحفل الغنائي الضخم في قلعه
تدفعها الحكومه نظرا الى انه حدث دوله
بمعنى ان العب يقع على الموازنه العامه
ودفع الضرائب في ظل ازمه تكلفه معيشه
يعاني منها الملايين
الملك اخذ الوضع الاقتصادي في الاعتبار
وحاول تقليص الفعاليات جزئيا ولكن اعتقد
ان الاغلبيه تؤيد اقامه حفل تتويج مشرف
لان فعاليات التتويج لا تاتي كل سنه او
حتى كل عقد ويجب ان تلتزم بمستوى عال
واحترام للتقاليد والتاريخ
وفي محاوله لمراعاه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
قلل الملك عدد المدعوين الى نحو 2000 مدعو
مقارنه بثمانيه الاف شخص حضروا تتويج
الملك الراحله المراسم الرسميه داخل كنيسه
واسمنسور ابي ايضا تمت تقليص مدتها من
ثلاث ساعات الى ما بين 90 دقيقه وساعتين
كما خصص الملك يوما يشجع فيه المواطنين
على التطوع والقيام بالاعمال الخيريه في
مجتمعهم للتجديد على اهتمامه بمساعده
الفقراء والمتضررين
الحكومه بدورها تقول ان الحفل سيجلب
مردودا سياحيا ضخما وسيعطي جرعه نشاطا
للاقتصاد كما يشير المسؤولون الى حقوق
البث لقنوات حول العالم التي من المتوقع
ان تحصل الملايين من الجنيهات للموازنه
اخر حفل تتويج كان قبل سبعين عاما فهو
فعليا حدث تاريخي واذا نظرنا الى احتفالات
اليوبيل البلاتينيه السنه الماضيه نقدر
انه جلب ملياري جنيه من الانفاق في
المطاعم والفنادق وفي منطقه الويست اند في
لندن المبيعات الاضافيه بلغت 80 مليون
جنيه ولا يزال جدل يدور حول الاجازه
الرسميه من مؤيد يقول انها ستدعم الاقتصاد
بنحو مليار جنيه من خلال الاستهلاك
والسياحه ومن معارض يحذر من تكلفه توقف
العمل قد تتجاوز ملياري جنيه ايا كانت
الفاتوره النهائيه لمراسم التتويج يعد
التحدي الاكبر بالنسبه للعائله الملكيه هو
اقامه احتفال يليق بض خامه هذا الحدث
التاريخي ولكن اخذا في الاعتبار الصعوبه
الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها البريطانيون
كارينا كامل العربيه لندن
ونتابع هذه الصور المباشره من لندن وقصر
للتحضيرات الجاريه
لتتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا
لبريطانيا اذا نتابع هذه الصور التي
تاتينا مباشره حيث يتاهب الملايين عبر
بريطانيا وغيرها من دول العالم لمشاهده
هذه المراسم لتتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث
هي احتفالات رمزيه بالطبع تجمع بين مراسم
دينيه ومظاهر الاوبا والعراق البريطانيه
التي تعود العالم على متابعتها في كل هذه
المناسبات والتي كان اخرها ربما وفاه
الملكه اليزابيث التي شهدت جنازه مهيبه
جدا تابعها الملايين حول العالم هذا الحدث
الان ياتي بعد فتره لتتويج الملك تشارلز
الثالث الثالث بالتاكيد ستقام هذه
في كنيسه وست منستر يوم غدا
وسيصبح بعد التتويج الملك تشارلز هو
وزوجته الملكه القرينه كاملا الملك رقم 40
الذي يتوج منذ العام
1066 اذا بالتاكيد العامه سيسمح لهم
بمتابعه هذا الاحتفال والتتويج وبالتاكيد
سيتوافدون الى لندن منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى للصفه على جانبي الطريق لمتابعه
هذه المراسم التي يدرك البريطانيون
اهميتها هذا التتويج منذ سنوات طويله لم
يتابع احد يعني اكثر من 70 عاما بقيت
الملكه الراحله لزياده على العرش وبالتالي
ياتي هذا التتويج بعد جيل كامل لم يشهد
تتويجا رغم ان هذه العمليه عريقه بريطانيا
وتمتد منذ اكثر من الف عام بالتاكيد هذه
الاحتفالات ستبدا غدا
بموكب رسمي ينطلق من قصر باكينغهام الى
كنيسه وست مونستر حيث سيسمح للمواطنين
الذين سياتون من داخل وخارج بريطانيا
لمتابعتها هناك
من سياتي وجاء من خارج بريطانيا لمتابعه
التتويج لانه هذا التتويج ايضا هو جزء من
السياحه التي تؤمنها بريطانيا رغم كل
الحديث
عن ربما الكلام والجدل الذي يدور حول
التكاليف هذا الحفل الذي ربما تتجاوز 100
مليون جنيه على كل حال لا ارقام حتى الان
مؤكده لكن بالتاكيد بان الحدث مهم وتعول
عليه بريطانيا لتستمر في هذه العادات
والتقاليد على كل حال هذه الساعه انتهت من
تغطيتنا نتحول مباشره الى الزميل نايف
الاحمري الذي يلتقيكم على راس الساعه
تفضلوا بالبقاء معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه الوثائقيات وتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات